all right folks Chris waters here at PAX
South taking a look at gigantic joining
me is Finny the creative director on the
game - hey how are you doing I'm good
man
look this is a competitive action game
team based lots of different character
classes want to get right into the
action shortly but we're just gonna take
a quick look yes an Azeri you have yeah
what we try to do is have heroes that
suit different play styles for this row
that we're going through right now these
are all range characters but even here
some of them are meant for people who
play shooters this guy who I think is
actually we're gonna run around with
today is actually more interesting skill
interactions more furtive RPG players
though aiming is still pretty important
and that's a tricky balance to put
shooter players RPG players to sort of
funnel that all into it yeah competes of
action experience but yeah yeah that's
the big thing is you know we've got a
team where everybody's really engaged
and we've given giving them freedom to
really sort of put themselves into the
art itself than the thing and we we talk
a lot about what we're trying to do and
really try to collaborate on it so all
of these things represent a whole team
of people getting together and trying to
say what do we think it's cool and being
able to do that well I've seen a few
that I think pretty cool let's go ahead
and choose our character and get
and you can sort of lay the foundation
for us about what gigantic is all about
yeah so five-on-five team-based combat a
gigantic because each team has a
gigantic Guardian and that's the the
goal of the match so if we look at like
the top of the screen there on the left
there is the health bar for the Nagas
that's this team's Guardian and on the
right is an red is the health bar of the
Griffon at the enemy team's Guardian if
they kill the enemy Guardian they win
the Guardian dies they lose so first
thing they're doing here is spreading
out and trying to take map control
they're these different points where you
can summon creatures he's chosen to
summon a tough Cerberus here this will
give his team detection service new
found enemy players so before that you
can't see enemies on the map one side
goes up now we can see where the enemies
are so that's a capture point that they
allow you to summon a variety of
creatures but does it have other
strategic importance in terms of the
progress of the match yeah definitely
they're the way to win of course killing
the enemy Guardian but to do that you
need to power up yours and go with him
when he attacks and you're in power in a
few different ways but map control is
one of the big ones and so if you hold a
lopsided amount it looks like there are
six points so teams have about three and
three a piece of a
try to break that stalemate yeah try to
tip the balance one way to increase the
power there yeah exactly so they went in
one of their guys well this big
engagement is happening in the middle
one of the guys one in the back killed
the enemy creature at sea now they've if
they've got a 3-2 edge they've also
gotten a kill kills or another way to
get power and so you can see they've got
a little edge there they're almost a
quarter of the way to powering up and
having their Guardian attack all right
speaking of attack let's talk about the
character we're seeing an action right
here obviously got some archery skills
seems a pretty nimble yeah so this is a
voting he is elusive he's kind of a
trickster so you can see he's got just
someone to decoy so that it looks like
he's still there and then ran around me
on the side you can see that that dance
that he did that's you know the game's
very action-oriented and a fast pace he
also drops down these poisoned clowns
and so that green area will poison any
enemies that enter into it as you play
you get to upgrade your hero and the the
upgrades actually change the
functionality so I think the first
upgrade he got was to the poison cloud
so instead of creating okay it's gotten
more than more than one just regularly
but instead of being able to just create
a poison cloud at his location you can
now shoot out the poison cloud and so
you can see poisons in that cave because
he took that upgrade shot it out there
sort of an area denial yeah and you
could have taken a different branch
where the poison becomes sort of more
powerful but it sort of stuck where
you're at and but he wanted to be the
ability to threaten other areas and
that's one of the ways that these
characters I mean you could they can
place like pretty significantly
differently depending on the forking
upgrades yes yeah and so you have to
look at how you like to play but also
your team you know if he had a lot of
other ability to sort of threaten at
range maybe it'd be more important for
him to go the other way with poison if
he's really playing an important role in
this team dealing with clusters of
enemies at range then being able to
shoot out the poison this big here you
see is pretty low health he's getting
healed by video see there and
so getting like alternately whacked by
this giant dragon tail that's out there
I noticed the power meter for yeah Naga
has reached full yes so what's gonna
happen I filled up their Naga is
travelling across the map now and he is
gonna give them an opportunity to get in
a position that he's gonna go attack the
enemy Guardian to see that message it's
going in now if his team can get in and
do enough damage they're gonna wound the
enemy Guardian you just have to do it
three times to win but you have to earn
that damage you have to get in there and
do it and as the other team is rushing
back there now it's a defense yeah well
you're busy attacking this giant thing
are they going to wipe you and get a
chance to push back or are they gonna
concede the wound and try to retake
control of the map while you're getting
the wound and so we try to put pressure
on you to go in different directions and
create opportunities for strategic
freedom so you can see he's gonna put
his decoy because it's a goodness little
poke battle around the corner with
damage as well he's quite strong the
decoy does a tiny amount of damage and
then he can upgrade at different ways he
could go around where it becomes really
a pretty strong turret or he can go out
where it becomes better in terms of
being elusive and deceptive like so what
he did there was he dropped down this
healing hidden sprinkle that also lets
you jump up high if you want because
he's being pursued by a thing with a
giant demon yeah that's the Margrave
it's got the the hand of a demon in it's
really hard it's also pretty tanky
sturdy character yeah so it needs to say
so yeah you don't want to get up next
all though again the super-jumping the
dodging that's all this evasion so I
think that that is like you know because
you've got you've got skills and your
basic maneuverability yeah mine's to
really make it action as much as just
sort of using your skills yeah yeah it's
a combination of thinking about how to
use your abilities and then just the
pure sort of twitch skills here matter a
lot so he's done skill upgrades he's
also done these sort of trait upgrades
it says passives in this building and
those give you other ways to improve
your character and we wanted to make
sure they're interesting combinations
that they're you know could be a lot of
discussion outside of a game of how you
wanted to mix and match your abilities
mm-hmm
and that's all within one match you know
yeah you're respecting your character
differently every time or if you yeah
thank you so choose
yep or you go this your paper bill but
yeah it all resets beginning this is
really close power wise next team to get
a kill is gonna get the attack and they
got it and so they're knocking even
though we see the other team gaining
almost gaining the power yeah now moved
into like defensive position because
they lost the Indiana the power that
they got even though the first actually
helps though it so you can see it's
shifted to blue this is a shield reduces
the damage that their Guardian takes so
they can build up try to build up power
before the attack takes place in order
to really protect them now does the
Guardian do the Guardians only have eyes
for each other and anyone else who's in
the way is collateral damage or if
you're near the enemy Guardian do you
really have to watch out yeah you do
need to be careful you can in fact
there's a third way to taking power
which is you can just go over the
Guardian and strike him in the heart you
won't do damage but you'll steal power
from him and give to your guy but you
got to look out because they've got some
really powerful attacks anytime they're
involved in a battle it can be very
dangerous and so trying to sneak around
back and chip away a little bit but so
we're still sort of waiting for the
Guardian attack to happen yes boy yeah
he's just getting ready I think he's in
position now in any moment we should see
yep there it is now he's gonna come in
now we're gonna get on row seats yeah
we're waiting for that if you knock down
and then hit him in the heart and you
can see almost got this wound this is
drawing on some console traditions there
where we finished the wound and now
though the Guardian recovers and now
it's time to get out and try and how to
get fluttered in here now as the
Guardian loses health and obviously
that's how the match yeah progresses
towards the end of the conclusion but
does does the gardens behavior or
position change as there there are a
couple big things that happen once we
get down to one of the Guardians being
on his last wound or just there have
been enough attacks it triggers what's
called The Clash those Guardians leave
their lairs and come out in the middle
we wanted to make sure that every match
ended with you know high drama exciting
for all yeah so everything becomes more
intense you can't summon any more
creatures at that point the creatures
you have still are they're still giving
power but it becomes really focused on
trying to teamfight that's possible now
we're watching some of your best
community players yeah in sort of the
alpha state here in gigantic what but
you know to me looking at what's going
on there's a lot of status effects
there's a lot of different characters
what are you guys doing in terms of
addressing the learning curve for the
game yeah I think that's a really big
issue nakum you're doing something new I
think a lot of the things in the game
are things that are pretty familiar to
anybody who's played a shooter or kind
of action RPG before but there are
definitely unique things so there's the
the polish that it being an alpha a lot
of it's not necessarily there yet that
you try to put in to make it game clear
but then you also have to look at what's
the new player experience jumping in
without ever having run around in any
kind of match with you know five hostile
players is maybe not the easiest
introduction so we know we have to make
sure that people can get in and just try
the game out in a sort of solo fashion
we're not gonna do big campaign or
anything like that but but enough that
you can be comfortable with your
characters and experiment with different
abilities and we've been seeing the
abilities sort of on this character I
mean there's been a lot of offensive a
little bit a lot of attacking the enemy
players is that the first death yeah I
think but there's other give us a taste
this from what other characters what
their play style might be like instead
of sort of yeah running around Flint
getting out you know sniping from afar
and then getting in these nimble battles
what's another way you could be in the
game yeah so just looking at his
teammates the ones we were looking at
there while he was dead we had a video
see she's a support character by sort of
basic nature she's kind of a floating
wispy lady with multiple arm
yeah orbs flying on yeah those orbs come
from her sacrificing her own life and
they power up her heels and so she
sacrifices her life to have these orbs
then she becomes a very strong human
although as with all the characters
there are different ways you can SPECT
them so she's good at healing but you
can also choose a different set of
upgrades so that she becomes a viable
damage dealer
on this team I think she'd probably
focus on the healing because she's got a
lot of other damage healers under cane
and then running in here breathing all
that fire he sees a lot of dropping down
Orion 14 there is Charnock he's a mage
and he does area effect damage sets
everybody on fire
he's actually got again a mix of play
styles where you can sort of build him
to stay back and drop fire in from a
distance we can build him to jump in and
set people on fire breathe fire which is
what we saw him doing he's got one
ability detonate where you do it it
caused an explosion where you're at and
sends you flying so we can use that to
move around the map in interesting ways
there's a guy's interesting those
abilities that are offensive or
defensive but double as mobility - yes
yeah so am i using it you know fortitude
to deal damage to evade or a little bit
of both and it looks like now we're in
the clash section yes
so we've hit the hit point words clash
this is so the the map will the match
will conclude and both the Guardians are
in here now we're you know fighting
around the Guardians there isn't as much
call to go and all the sort of extreme
sides of the map we generally have the
Guardian to actually reshape the
battlefield when they come out and smash
stuff up because this map is still under
development they don't really do that so
there'll be some spots where it's a
little tight around the Guardians but
they reshape it so we make the right
arena for the final conflict look for
more focused yeah engagement now I
looking at the health of these two
Guardians we've come to the clash but is
there any hope that the teams as their
guardian is there is gonna be defeated
even though it has full health there
would have been if they managed to get a
couple more kills there you see that
last segment this team got six kills out
here we got three if they manage to get
a couple more kills they could have
gotten power first okay and then a shot
at a woman yeah and then what they would
have needed to do was take over a little
bit more than map and you can chip away
there all the mechanics are actually
designed so that you have to earn it but
you can you can come back very cool
finis well that was a great victory
exciting to watch a match of gigantic in
progress you guys have any idea when
some folks are gonna be able to get into
the match themselves if they're watching
this video well you know we're running
the Alpha right now they go to go
gigantic calm and they'll be able to
sign up
fantastic thanks so much okay thank you